we don't worry about they so this is the
question from Stephen King on Facebook I
assume I hope kinda thirsty okay is what
is the likelihood of creating a
real-world arc reactor like an Ironman
the the kind of artificial arc reactor
heart that he has what if any negative
effects would be present if you were to
house something like that within the
human chest cavity yeah so I like that
question so so that's a huge oh by the
way so so I resonate more with Batman
than with Ironman because the energy
source for Ironman is too too remote for
me to embrace that right but if you
energy depends on how you store it if
it's stored thermally would be very very
hot right if you store it
electromechanical II you'd have a lot of
what are effectively wound up Springs
mm-hmm all right
the month many ways you can store energy
you can sort chemically that's what you
have in the form of gunpowder it's
sitting there ready to explode but it's
not so its energy built in chemically
that you can think of mechanically think
of thermally and so um if you if it was
thoroughly it would eventually heat him
up right you wouldn't be able to
insulate it perfectly and so that would
be bad for him that'd be bad on her
chemical way that you'd have in the way
of a gun powder where you would have a
store of it and it would I would have
small I think the best man jewelry
actions other parts of it the best way
to do that is to have a repository of
antimatter keep it separate from the
matter mm-hmm it was some kind of
magnetic bottle you can't put it in a
regular bottle you're writing this down
fine later going back to your lab
where's the antimatter and then you'd
leak out little bits of it to merge with
the matter and then you'd have energy at
your disposal and there'd be no bad side
effects or antimatter when we come back
to the cosmic queries part of star talk
radio the subject superheroes seen a
moment